jacques alain lamberton bonsoir oui je
reste avec vous alors comme vous le
savez chers amis chers ennemis a eu un
petit scandale
cette semaine c'est à dire que les
galeries lafayette dans leurs vitrines
ont mis des mannequins vivants
donc on va en parler dans un instant
avec roselyne bachelot qui s'est insurgé
contre ça en disant que ça ressemblait
aux prostituées d'amsterdam
vous connaissez les prostituées
d'amsterdam bien sûr tout le monde
connaît qui mangent des frites comme
exutoire ce n'était pas des plus tard
donc on va en parler avec elle
j'accueille pour l'hyper view roselyne
bachelot
bonsoir on chantait de faire votre
connaissance on se laisse alors vous
connaissez rossinien non notre kiné pub
du rosé chez elle allée du dos mais
habillé de rose de piétons capsat à
seattle mais c'est plus cher andré
bercoff je pensais qu'il avait un
pantalon cuir et non aux différents
centres entre cécile boutin et madame
bachelot les roses fuchsia et l'autre
héros se fait chier voir christina non
plus un petit torchon sur l'épaule pour
nom vous confondez la caméra rafadh
cessé de checchi votre petit léo là
c'est ma petite couture c'est vous qui
l'avez dessiner mais c'est très joli
bond line
donc vous savez ce qu'est une hyper ça
c'est pas terrible je me moque pas des
c2 vous l'a largement vous venez de
faire des compliments à ces deux dames
et rien à la menace qu'elle n'a pas
voulu s'habiller comme je voulais
c'était de la tricoter c'est bien à
roselyne vous connaissez l'hyper view il
n'avait pas beaucoup de l'aisne joue
donc j'y perds views on en rêve tous
vous posez des questions andré andré
vous pouvez poser des questions à
roselyne valérie peut poser
devenez creusement de poser c'est le
principe de l' hyper dur on se met à
cinq contrats alors roselyne bachelot
vous appelez en fait bronzer une j'ai vu
bachelot narquin parce que le nom de
repères c'est marca bachelot ces deux
noms de votre premier mari et comme
souvent en politique on garde le nom d'
et vous regrettez maintenant d'avoir
commencé votre carrière professionnelle
sous un nom qui n'est pas le mot de
passe que vous avez divorce est
maintenant de ces problèmes de beaucoup
de formes
on commence sa carrière sous un nom le
nom de son mari
aujourd'hui pour que les femmes gardent
leur nom de jeune fille parce que les
hommes passent et le nom reste à jake et
jake s'est pourtant fait quand vous lui
aviez payer ses études à vous aviez tout
fait mon jacques bon yvette roudy qui
s'appelait il va te horner ont dit oui
jamais dû changer alors maintenant donc
l'hyper duo va vraiment commencer serge
khalfon est-ce qu'on peut mettre la
voilà à on est mieux là j'ai fut cheikh
dans les yeux de ces grosses dragin
s'avoue plus si c'est très jeune et très
jolie
vous êtes très fier très voyante c'est
tout les quand on vous voit quand on
vous voit on est d'accord pour qu'il ait
plus de femmes à l'assemblée à aller
vraiment mais c'est pas pour ça vous moi
je suis pour qu'ils aient plus de femmes
à l'assemblée on va en parler après
vous êtes né le 24 décembre comme jésus
à minuit à minuit vous êtes capricorne
comme jésus 1 c'est un bon signe
capricorne organise sa saison vierge à
entendant dire comme zizou vous êtes
député du maine-et-loire député rpr
alors vous dites toute façon le rpr
c'est ma famille parce que il ya une
chose c'est assez incroyable c'est que
le général de gaulle vous a embrassé
quand vous aviez neuf mois et demi et
c'est un peu comme dans le temps quand
napoléon avait embrassé quelqu'un à ce
que j'entends je sais ça est une sorte
d'adoubement voyez vous accrocher mon
père m'a emmené le général de gaulle
m'embrasser depuis ce temps-là jeu bah
oui voilà votre père était résistant pas
été député avant d'aider peas étaient
résistants et ftp votre mère était
féministe donc on comprend ça explique
un peu aussi votre vos positions
actuelles quand vous avez été élevé là
dedans donc vous de cv comme ça en vita
pas votre cv vos activités vous êtes
présidente c'est assez étonnant parce
que c'est pas très politiquement correct
vous êtes présidente du groupe d'études
france irak et du groupe d'amitié france
syrie donc on va pas faire une soirée
triste et le présidente pour l'europe de
l'association parlementaire ou à revoir
donc ça c'est rare en plus des gens qui
s'engagent comme ça pour les pour les
pays arabes en france on va faire une
soirée triste mais enfin vous vous êtes
témoin que les bombarder des gens ça
sert à rien en irak en tout cas
certainement pas oui je suis allé
visiter l'ira qui a à peu près un mois
et demi et j'ai pu constater sur place
la détresse des populations
c'est assez terrifiant voilà mêmes les
israéliens qui ont bien un filtre elle
une scop disent que saddam n'est
vraiment plus dangereux tous les experts
militaires internationaux sont d'accord
pour dire que le potentiel militaire
irakien est complètement détruit le
potentiel nucléaire chimique heures
creuses l'irak ont fait des trous
partout en irak on trouve rien et on
demandera irakiens pouvaient que
vraiment y'a rien voilà difficile voilà
donc
on va passer tant que là dessus mais
enfin on en conclura ce qu'on voudra sur
d'autres frappes alors vous soutenez
aussi la cause palestinienne enfin c'est
pas très politiquement correct au
contraire c'est très polluants dans les
barrages en attendait beaucoup de gens
en france se plaindre qu'on ait repoussé
l'indépendance de la palestine d'un mois
et demi
alors s'il 4 mai 6 4 mais les temps s'il
n'y en ait pas mais pour proclamer que
ça retarde d'un mois c'est pas très
grave
d'accord mais si véritablement ça
mettait ça m'était en saura un jour on
sait très bien que ça cependant dominant
non bagués une résolution de l'onu qui
n'est pas acquis n'est pas appliquée bon
le problème c'est pas vraiment entre
l'état estime yannis règne entre les
juifs et les arabes eux manifestement et
si je veut résumer grossièrement oui
c'est encore plus compliqué que ça enfin
ou bien encore politique c'est
simplement pour dire que vous étiez
quelqu'un effectivement on va passer
maintenant à vos autres positions
politiques mais enfin ne serait-ce que
là-dessus déjà vous avez des positions
qui sont pas banales alors vous êtes
beaucoup engagé pour la parité
homme-femme vous publiez un livre alors
avec quelqu'un qui est pas du tout de
votre banque et geneviève fraisse qui
est numéro deux sur la liste de robert
hue voilà donc je le montre à la caméra
comme on fait la télé voilà c'est
blanche-neige et les derrière robert
moussignac alors que geneviève fraisse
et pour les bombardements de l'otan
oui tout à fait donc déplacé que vous
avez chanté intéressant c'est de se
confronter et là les pas du tout votre
bord et alors il n'ya pas sur la
couverture ghislaine ottenheimer qui
pourtant a participé activement au livre
donc on le dit on le dit l éditeur donc
ça s'appelle deux femmes au royaume des
hommes chez hachette littératures donc
sur la parité vous avez dit aux
sénateurs de droite qui étaient contre
la parité
il avait une occasion de se racheter de
temps de vilenie contre les femmes
depuis un siècle de république
ils n'ont pas saisi l'occasion quelques
ont pour eux un c'était pour les femmes
parce que je pense qu'on va très bien se
débrouiller sans eux mais c'est vrai
qu'ils avaient une belle occasion
d'apparaître pour peut-être parce qu'il
n'était pas et ils ont été fidèles à
leur tradition c'est pas tous à tous à
un ami très humaine ne sait pas traiter
de vieux cons voilà les lauriers du co2
pour vous auriez dû c'est pas du tout
quand on sera vieux con sans l'atteindre
relate m
oui je trouve ah oui c'est le faire
pardon des pouvoirs voulue lors duquel
qu'on est pas qu elle bit au nom
justement de la parité à vrai vous avez
raison ça me révolte un peu envie qu'on
pour employer justement pourquoi on a
fait de ce mot con un mot péjoratif
alors vous aurez traité de beats aura
été aussi fort et vous aurez été bon non
mais quelquefois je dis ça comme une
[ __ ] à la commune c'est pas mal ce
besoin pour la parité vous à l'assemblée
nationale où vous vous en foutez
complètement non je m'en fous pas je
m'en fous ouais moi je sais pas parce
que si on met non non non je pense que
ce soit je ne suis pas pour qu'on mette
un nombre de femmes à nombre de jeux je
pense que soit on est doué qu'on peut y
a je sais pas je trouve que les quotas
j'aime moins les quotas que ce que vous
pensez que les 95 % d'hommes qui sont en
politique ils sont doués annonce a eu
peur
non mais je me dis que de faire
absolument un quota il faut 50% de
femmes 50% donne 50 % voilà où dans les
films il faut un noir un chinois une
femme homosexuelle un ballet si on a
toujours un noir il y avait déjà donné
dans la première partie position il y
avait celui ci va arriver annoncé dans
les colonnes mais maintenant je trouvais
très bien que la politique est sur la
ligne d'elisabeth badinter c'est une
universelle en attendant moi je suis
plutôt content quand même que des
vieilles prisons
vous êtes d'accord que si on commence
sur la parité ça n'a rien à voir avec
l'universalisme de la république assez
clair on commence à faire des
segmentations entre les gens pourquoi un
jour on dirait pas à l'assemblée il faut
qu'il y ait ce que les 13% d'homosexuels
15% noir en sexuelle n'a rien à voir
avec toutes les autres différences elle
est fondatrice de l'humanité toutes les
autres différents son contingent de
transitoire vous avez dit la véritable
égalité en droit comme ça c'est qu'ils
s'emmerdent abbas s'est passé c'est une
boule quies non c'est une heure est donc
dans le car on dit la série est ce que
vous ne l'a prêté c'est juste comme
c'est vraiment là parce que moi je suis
pour ma part j'étais aussi tirer une
prothèse auditive parce que vous êtes un
peu parce qu'il ya un truc aliens amer
il me dit toujours comment se fait il qu
ardisson qui aère plus petit que toi
sois plus grand à l'écran est comme ça
d'un coup
l'accoucheur non si vous la trouvez ça
des talons mais il a dépensé 6 6 est-ce
qu l'art bon vous me la rendre
donc là on expliquant sa main n'est pas
facam à deux secondes alors madame barbe
est allé lui parler lui oui c'est madame
parent de huy où certains de ces madame
parts de marché j'entends un petit bruit
de fond non je pense que c'est ça ne
marche que sur vous ah parce que moi qui
valait trois milliards
il ya des trucs ses atouts les trois
mineurs ça m'arrangerait bien tiens
austin machin je ne sais pas alors
roselyne ouais vous avez des austin
powers ça ça lui plaît à le mercier ce
genre de fille vous avez dit la
véritable égalité c'est quand il y aura
des femmes potiche à l'assemblée sur le
compte de l'égalité
c'est comme il ya des députés petit je
suis aussi des députés potiche femmes
c'est ce que je dis valérie quant à lui
dit ah oui tout le monde ait choisi sur
ses qualités sur ses mérites en
politique c'est évidemment pas vrai ça
se fait je ne savais pas voilà on
s'affaire dans un milieu dans mon
travail vous ça n'est pas comme ça que
ça se passe
voilà bah ouais y'a que des gens
remarquables la marque et en parle il
faut que je fasse du cinéma là c'est
parti pour vous est vachement doué avec
cette boutade bonne comédienne
voilà elle est meilleure que moi non non
non non alors lanka et louise vient me
parler du pacs je me redresse bien pour
que la maman de l'enfant rappelle mes
années avec jacques martin sympa alors
non on vient de parler la parité sur le
pacs à vous êtes de bons vous avez vous
avez marqué contre votre camp on peut
dire vous êtes devenu d'alger a requis
pour le mien pour le vôtre vous êtes
devenu d'après le magazine têtu qui est
une lecture très saine vous êtes devenu
une icône qui cire que vous êtes devenu
une idole des gains une madone des aussi
je vous avais fait la couverture de têtu
comment vous êtes tabloïds en plus que
c'est un journal qui est de l'union que
qui est très très bien fait donc vous
êtes une icône gay alors quand quand
vous êtes à l'assemblée et que vous vous
prêchez comme ça pour propos pour le
pacs les les gens vous disent roselyne
s'est tue près le passé pour f
est ce que je trouve extraordinaire
c'est que chaque fois qu'une femme un
peu de courage ou un peu de personnalité
on fait une comparaison viril oui j'ai
entendu
voilà une femme qui a des couilles et
voilà mon film c'est ce qu'on dit
martine aubry en effet ce qu'est ce
qu'on vit vers les couilles en plus
voilà moi j'attends qu'un jour on dit
d'un homme courageux il à dessein oui ah
oui pas bien ne pas fonder s'attaquer
pas le pape l'a jadis tout sauf à ça
contre l'utilisation du préservatif je
voulais pas qu'ils encouragent la
débauche et là la décadence le pape en
france c'est le jean pierre coffe autres
religions et entre sur scène
c'est pas mal quand c'est drôle bon oui
d'ailleurs vous alors vous avez des
expressions marque et vous êtes vous
fait vous êtes un discours à l'assemblée
qui en sortant comme ça c'était très dur
pour vous ce discours à l'assemblée donc
sur le pacs et en sortant vous dit ouais
c'est un peu j'ai un peu perdu les
pédales quand même si vous dites
n'importe quoi maintenant ici quand on
vous parle j'ai eu moi aussi j'ai un peu
perdu au sujet vous savez du hacking
c'est-à-dire que act up voulait dénoncer
le député de droite qu'avec est
homosexuel et qu'ils allaient manifester
contre le pacs est un des députés de
droite où le moustique ça et député de
droite ou moins sexuelle très
intéressant à votre avis combien mais
écoutez moi j'ai fait mali c'est pour
vous dire des non non non non non non
non le nombre mais quand ils ont menacé
de out et je regardais les gars qui
étaient complètement blanc dans les
couloirs et je me disais pas que ça y
est c'est lamentable
les voici
vous avez déclaré commission
parlementaire au sujet de ses députés
vous avez déclaré dans tabloïd
ce n'est pas parce qu'on est homosexuel
qu'on est pour le pacs et vice versa
bout et quand même que vous avez des
formules oui ça oui nous mais la raison
oui et vous avez dit d'ailleurs la
sexualité du député en question je
m'attaque je m'en tape
ou plutôt je me retape d'appui avancer
une marrante
elle est chouette
en fait est ce que finalement
je rêve que je ne sois pas fan aussi
d'habitude les femmes remarquer c'est
pas vrai parce que comment il s'appelle
c'est mon côté maso françoise de
panafieu été plus tôt six autres femmes
du rhdp reconnaît pas et je m'en reste
le chinois tout en sa bon je vais quand
même un sens vous avez dit je vous avez
un ami vous comme malgré tout comme un
peu repères parce que c'est un ami qui
est mort du sida et vous avez dit qu'à
la fin de sa vie il était en rupture
avec la surconsommation sexuelle façon
cyril collard qui ne peut conduire qu'au
chagrin au désespoir à la maladie vous
avez quand même
thiam pour vous les [ __ ] les bons pdc
d'épée des sages quand même le nom de
font ce qu'ils veulent ce qu'ils veulent
nous avait séduit livewii ils avaient
ils avaient beaucoup souffert dans sa
vie et il avait souhaitée avec ta un ami
établir un lien entre tous oui dans une
fatwa ou pas souhaité vous dit quand
même que pour l'heure il est arrivé il
en était arrivé à un couple sage contre
la surconsommation sexuelle type cyril
collard sûr quand même que vous vous
critiquer quand même un peu le côté back
room
si oui il faut que je critique pas
chacun fait ce qu'il veut mais il ya des
gens qui sont malheureux oui peut-être
que vous précisiez pour les
téléspectateurs qui ne savent pas tous
forcément ce que c'est qu'un pack rouge
et les insultes room mais pas une
épreuve de répétition pour les candidats
au bac
pas de persuader tout le monde sache ce
que c'est qu'un batroun dans les boîtes
vous allez vous savez ce que ça allait
les hétéros qui vont dans les bordels
sont malheureux mais enfin je suis allée
board alors été shirt trop m'attendais à
contacter richard
en vieille histoire ça non mais je crois
qu'il faut pas généraliser
oui à pas il ya des surconsommateurs
sexuels qui sont très heureux il y avait
des gens qui ont des engrais dans les
bois dans les boîtes gays dans les
boîtes gays
il ya des endroits un peuple en noir
noir comme ça parce que nous on va où on
va ou ne va pas manger trop gras
lui il se passe des choses assez libre
10 ans 1 et il y a déjà dit il ya des
parois comme ça avec des trous dedans
dans la paroisse qu'on appelle des glory
haut à gauche heureusement il a regardé
promettent la tribune on admire attenant
gens expliquait alors le glory hole on
passe on passe bien le ring lors que
l'on passe son sexe c'est pas possible
de finir on passe son sexe en gorille au
tour on ne sait pas qui vous valérie
fait pipi merci maman merci
je crois que dans l'oreillette qu'elle a
gardée ont bien dû dire il y en a 1
derrière le studio et elle est partie
vérifier en fait le duo réole donc c'est
un petit trou on en accueille les parois
avec des petits trots on passe son sexe
bon je peux titre aux conseillers staff
le mur derrière il ya quelqu'un qui vous
fait ce qu'il veut mais on ne savait pas
qui c'est beaucoup mais en repli me
dites pas que vous ne connaissiez pas
les glory je connais les as khroub je
vais pas l'idiot les jeunes sang et or
qui avaient ça se savait pas que c'était
comme ça à chaud comme ça que société où
est-ce que vous avez vu ça dans un bac
rom mais qui fait taper chez pas une
râpe à fromage il essaie on peut dire
que l'assemblée nationale c'est le back
room du sénat bon alors finalement
sourire et avec sa lampe torche
absolument est-ce qui est ce que
finalement vous n'êtes pas utile au rpr
est ce que finalement vous n'êtes pas un
peu vous faites du bien oui repères
quand on voit à françoise de panafieu
comme on l'a vu ici quand on vous voit
vous vous faites du bien ou rpr c'est
évident peut-être parce que quand je
vois le nombre de collègues qui m'invite
à tenir des réunions de leurs
circonscriptions après m'avoir dit vouer
aux gémonies je me dis ils sont quand
même c'est vraiment la base des emails
et la mercier d'entre vous est ce que
vous êtes gaulliste de gauche ou
progressistes de droite gaulliste de
gauche
vous êtes des églises de gauche elle a
pu la llave charbonnel oui souvenez-vous
l'a embrassée sur la joue gauche
c'est un charles de gaulle numéro deux
sur la liste de jean marie le pen se
fait gerber moi je pense qu'il est plus
de la famille du porte-avions du général
ville un peu trop court pour réussir à
décoller le pen l'argent de klaus aux
frères la renier oui très bien que sa
prise aux méthodes changent il fait
partie des goodies de google petit fils
jean de luz et le fils de l'amiral
donc vous vous êtes vraiment c'est
jurassic park ainsi que les gaullistes
de gauche à marier mais on ne l'a plus
vu mon sens il ya venait qu'à fit jamais
recherché e mail oui je vais et pascual
gallo régis debray c'est un peu des
gaullistes de gauche
alors depuis 68 la droite court après la
gauche est ce que vous faites pas la
même chose sur depuis 68 finalement les
gens de droite dont jean michel c'est
ressembler à la jauge quoi c'est s'est
planté qui ont abdiqué
c'est là c'est la défaite idéologique
elle est à gauche en garde des jasmins
il essaye d'imiter la droite il fait une
politique de droite comme vous ouais
c'est les vidéos il a renoncé à tous il
a capitulé en rase campagne
ils ont baissé les plaindra il fait une
politique qui n'a rien à voir avec la
gauche c'est pour ça qu'ils réussissent
mais c'est depuis mitterrand ça c'est
vrai strauss kahn il fait pas tellement
peur aux bourgeois on s'en veut pas dire
qu'on ne veut pas dire non at elle sa
plusieurs sur le coup au gouvernement on
parlait jamais connu autant dire vous
avez vos interviews pourquoi non parce
que ce je préfère ce qui ce qui m'a vu
c'est de me moquer des gens qu'on n'a
pas l'habitude de voir et voilà non mais
sans vous en vous moquer des gens
pourriez parler politique sans vous
embaucher mais je gens parlent
d'ailleurs dans le derrière je me moque
d'une certaine gauche caviar qu'on voit
jamais au cinéma donc
sans dire sans imiter sans être
imitatrice de gens de d'hommes
politiques je pense que ces politiques
de tout à coup se moquer d'eux un peu
rue de valois votre personnage annoncé
des gens qu'on voit jamais au cinéma on
voit toujours des hommes qui brasse de
l'argent les gens qui travaillent et la
culture se salissent jamais les deux
voies avec de l'argent mais non c'est
vrai qu'on est mieux pouvoir mais c'est
très bien mais pas vu encore il faut les
voir salle à manger une voie non mais
sérieusement je dis pas ça parce qu'elle
est là parce que je le dis depuis que
j'ai vu le film il faut aller voir ce
film c'est formidable c'est une
caricature de la gauche caviar
pierre bien sûr vous avez vraiment rire
on va là derrière les christine boutin
chinois mais même alors dites moi il ya
peu de députés femmes donc je crois
qu'il ya 5,6 pour cent
maintenant on est un petit peu plus de
10 ha diskan ben oui on doit être au
niveau de la grèce maintenant oui on
était en amour en dernière place on est
passé en avant dernier devant ce mec
l'enfer pour vous qui est plutôt jolie
fille non parce qu'ils sont très
dragueur les hommes politiques n'ont
bani naim atteint aussi je constate que
les hommes politiques ne drague jamais
les femmes politiques ne drague que des
pétasses à
pourquoi alors mes françoise voulait
être la compagne de françois hollande
cet état là non c'est un couple un
couple légitime à bâle les hommes
politiques drac plus que les autres
par pourquoi ce qu'ils sont habitués à
séduire parce que je crois
qu'effectivement il ya plusieurs raisons
1 d'abord et il ya un caractère de
l'homme politique qui porte à flers
minergie être ensuite la politique c'est
très durement qu'ils ont besoin de se
consoler sur un ca maternelle a fait le
repos du guerrier voilà et puis
troisième raison c'est qu'ils ont
l'occasion bobonne vous attend 19h04
19h05 vous n'êtes pas là l'action j'ai
envie de chez le comice agricole le
meeting le truc et puis ce sont des
rockstars oui ou pis militants
voilà c'est vrai qu'à la cheffe de parti
arrive quelque part
equidia meeting et que l'ap une groupie
est là mais c'est un mondial quand il
sort de scène ya 55 il ya tant de gens
là j'aurais bien gentils et pas le dit
d'ailleurs quand on voit le nombre de
mines est qui tournicotent autour des
jeux grosse et c'est incroyable parce
que maria pleine lunette ou sans drm au
bar je suis sûr qu'il y en a mais vous
rappeler c'était henry kissinger le
pouvoir est aphrodisiaque
mais comment tu arrives toi avec ta
gueule à avoir tout ce que tu as et 10
et pouvoirs aphrodisiaques
les hommes politiques c'est vous qui le
faisait remarquer c'est que quand ils
sont la tribune il sait boury feu ils
deviennent un peu tout rouge comme des
coqs quoi c'était quelque chose de
commun orgasmique oui voilà il ya une
montée de ce en quoi je fais mais les
femmes alors n'être pas dragueuse non au
citoyen ajouté
wind u100 faire c'est pas du tout à me
pétrole et je dirais même que c'est même
l'inversé les précieuses non mais
ça chez moi il était alors biblique
bouzid roselyne bachelot les uns c'est
la chaire et ça fait du bien l'émission
a glissé ce qu'on vous avait dit samedi
d'avoir tous à vos pieds parce qu il
aime ça en plus les mecs
s'ils savent qu'il récupère vite truies
une famille française par la terreur
qu'est-ce que vous êtes avec rod est ce
qu'avec votre jules vous n'êtes pas que
c'est non en nous mais vous appeler
toute la journée il paraît sur wii il
est éteint la halle à le portage mais
c'est vrai que les hommes politiques ils
ont un peu l'habitude de tripoter les
gens chirac par exemple il tripote les
gens les vaches aussi le contact est
très fine de barthez a dit vous avez dit
que je suis là dessus maintenant qu'elle
est terrible l'émission problème vous
engage vous dites que chirac quand il
est question des femmes il vous
horripile wii u m'horripile un peu parce
qu'il n'est pas pour la conception
volontariste de la parité là je vais
commencer dans l'oreillette affaire on
dira que ça c'est bien
non me dis que ça va encore vous êtes
très bien lui c'est un vrai séducteur du
président la république
ah oui oui c'est un oui c'est un vrai
séducteur c'est un vrai trip auteurs
loyers bien
alors pour conclure cette petite île
perdue au fait vous jamais véronique 1
par l'est ou par l'ouest bon signe vous
avez un portable avec
avec robert vous appelé dans la journée
sur le portable ah oui non si vous êtes
obligé avec le décalage horaire vous a
quand vous vous couchez islam non halal
à diminuer cette affaire un drôle
d'effet et saluant même un méfait
sentais pas tout seul si là je me sens
très sainte marie laforêt le regard
s'allume à dire nos bd je viens dans
l'émission j'ai vous diront côté un peu
sur vous parce que nous on s'en souvient
mais moi je restais couple qui s'aime
c'est formidable même si à 12h et et
trois océans entre ces îles en rajoute
un seul mec de françois vous avez
déclaré
vous avez déclaré roselyne les hommes
doivent apprendre que les femmes ne sont
plus tout à fait dix mois vous avez dit
sam c'est ça m'a fait de la peine parce
que moi ma petite flamme je pensais
qu'elle était tout un mois et ben non
c'est voyager mais c'est vrai c'est vrai
les hommes doivent apprendre que les
femmes sont plus tout à chérie je suis
pas moins quand même un bébé d'un mois
non non bon vous restez avec nous un
petit peu là on va parler de des
galeries lafayette parce que